[APPLAUSE]
ADAM ROGERS: Hi.
Thank you for coming in,
forgoing the Google cafeteria
for a lunchtime--
nobody forewent it?
It didn't get foregone?
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
I want to do a little
calibration first.
How many of you are scientists,
computer or otherwise here?
How many of you are drinkers?
Any drinkers in the room.
It's my people, hi.
[LAUGHTER]
Good to see you.
I'm sure we've run into
each other in the bar.
So, we're going to be
talking about drinking
and talking about it with, I
hope, a little bit of context.
Other people have talked
about drinks before.
Someone else, for example, this
gentleman you recognize him,
any history people?
That's Ben Franklin.
He's quoted famously as
saying that wine is proof
that God loves us.
Which is actually
pretty profound,
because it gets at
the idea that there
is some kind of connection
between booze and the divine,
right?
Or I suppose between us
and divine, if you will.
Nothing, nobody cares
for the dumb puns?
I would think that would
be-- all right, fine.
I'm going to do more of them,
so you have to get used to it.
That's a thing that's
going to happen
for the next few minutes.
That's actually misquote.
It's not what Franklin said.
What Franklin actually said
was that the rain falling
on grapes, which then
are made into wine,
is a constant proof that
God loves us and wants
to see us happy.
And that's actually
even more potent.
Because it indicates
an intimate connection
with the process with nature.
And that's part of what
I want to argue today.
It's not my favorite booze quote
though, the Franklin quote.
My favorite one comes from
him, any English majors?
AUDIENCE: Ogden Nash?
ADAM ROGERS: Close.
William Faulkner.
Not close at all.
[LAUGHTER]
I thought the Ogden
Nash was a car.
Wasn't that a Ford or something?
No.
Noted drinker, William
Faulkner, who said this,
"Civilization begins
with distillation."
And so we could be good high
school English students first
and talk about the
metaphor there, right.
That civilization is about
boiling down and getting
to the essence of stuff.
And that's the etymology
of the word, sure.
It's the etymology
of the word yeast
too, interestingly,
not a coincidence.
But I want today to be
more literal about it.
I'm going to argue that the
human relationship with booze
is actually the story of how
Homo sapiens became people.
It's the way that
we settled down.
It's how we became civilized.
It's how we learned to
use what was happening
in our environment naturally.
And eventually, how we learned
to make something completely
new, how we became
technological.
OK.
So, can I prove this?
Let me try.
We'll start here,
at the beginning.
That's yeast,
saccharomyces cerevisiae,
sugar-eating mushroom
that makes beer.
The name is a little
on the nose perhaps.
But what yeast
does, fundamentally,
is eats sugar and then excretes
carbon dioxide and ethanol,
the alcohol that we drink.
Don't panic.
There's only one more that looks
like this in the whole deck.
This is only interesting
for two reasons.
This is a yeast metabolism.
This is what made
sure that I was not
going to be a biologist.
This made sure that I
was going to be a writer.
But two things I want
to point out here.
The green, the little green down
in the lower right, is energy.
ATP is the way a yeast
and you and I make energy.
And it's what we use for-- it's
the power source in our bodies.
So this is yeast taking in
glucose, up in the upper left,
turning it into ATP.
But then the box is
the interesting part.
Because the box is
yeast using an enzyme
called alcohol dehydrogenase
1 to turn something called
acetaldehyde into ethanol
and then excreting it.
But also using alcohol
dehydrogenase 2
to take that ethanol and
convert it back to acetaldehyde.
Basically, yeast eats its
own poop is the point.
But that brings to rise
an important question.
Why does yeast make alcohol?
Not philosophically, it's not
like an existential question.
But evolutionarily, why
does yeast make alcohol?
So there's two possibilities,
prompted by that little box.
One of them is that ethanol
is chemical warfare.
What do you do when you
want to clean out a cut?
Use alcohol.
Alcohol's really good
at killing microbes.
It's a microbicide.
So maybe yeast is using ethanol
to kill competitors locally.
Yeast can tolerate really
high levels of ethanol.
Other microbes can't.
It makes its own
chemical weapon.
So that's what ADH
1 suggests, right?
Or ADH 2 says well, maybe
ethanol is just a food source.
It's storing away nuts for the
winter, in the microbial way,
right?
So which is it?
How do you figure that out?
That is what this
guy tried to do.
This is a researcher
named Steven Benner.
He invented a field
called paleogenetics.
Paleogenetics is a
little bit like-- you
know how linguists
will try to figure out
what the first word
for something was,
by looking at what the word
is in all different languages
and finding what the
similarities are,
and trying to back trace it?
He figured out you could do
the same thing for enzymes.
That if you would take all
the samples of that enzyme
from a bunch of
different organisms,
in this case
Saccharomyces cerevisiae
yeast and the
water-related species,
look at the various alcohol
dehydrogenase enzymes,
you could build, as he
did-- his team did--
12 different versions
of the primordial ADH,
what the first one looked like.
They called it adhA.
They didn't know exactly
how it was going to work,
so they had 12
different versions.
And what they wanted to
do was run the equation.
Let it run, look
at the kinetics,
and see what it wanted to do.
Did it want to make
acetaldehyde into ethanol
or make ethanol
into acetaldehyde.
So they did it.
And what happened?
Turned out adhA was a
lot more like the one
that made the ethanol.
Yeast wants to make ethanol.
So problem solved.
Chemical weapon, right?
No, of course not.
It's not that easy.
I said that yeast eats sugar.
150 million years ago,
when yeast are first
figuring this out,
where's the sugar?
Sugar cane hasn't evolved
yet, because grasses
haven't evolved yet.
Sugar cane is a grass.
Well, plants, where yeasts
live, were mostly conifers.
They were like pine trees,
like on the right there.
No, my right.
Yeast probably lived exposed
to the air on these things,
on tree sap exudates,
on little blurbs of sap.
Like when you come
near a pine tree
and you get sap on your hand.
That's where the yeast lived.
And so, because
ethanol is volatile,
it wants to
evaporate-- and that's
going to be important later
as a property-- that's
a really good property to
have in a waste product.
That's perfect sewage.
Have ethanol, and
then it evaporates.
But then about 100 million
years later-- sorry,
about 50 million years
later, 100 million years ago,
in the Cretaceous
period, the fruity plants
take over from the pine trees,
the fruiting flowering plants.
Those are the angiosperms.
The other plant
there is amborella,
it's the very first angiosperm.
And yeast now are pre-adapted to
live inside those fruits, where
all the simple sugar is
that they want to eat,
because they can tolerate
higher level levels of ethanol.
They're making
their own ethanol,
and they can hang out
inside that fruit.
So they look pre-evolved,
they look ready.
What it actually is
is a coincidence.
But because they're
adapted to do that,
they have the luck
to do what needs
to be done in a changing world.
Because the other animals that
couldn't handle the change
to angiosperms, to flowering
fruiting plants, went extinct.
It was an extinction level
event for like-- well, let's
put it this way.
The dinosaurs that
figured out how
to deal with fruiting
flowering plants are birds.
The point I want to make
about this mostly-- other
than I just kind of think
it's a cool set of deductions
from the lab-- is
that fermentation
happens without us.
It doesn't need us.
If yeast makes
ethanol in the forest,
does anyone get drunk
to hear it or something.
Right, like if nobody's
there, it still happens.
There's still fermentation.
It occurs.
It occurred for millions
and millions of years
before human beings
came on the scene.
But then we did.
So this is a shard
of a pot that's
9,000 or 10,000 years old,
found in an archaeological site
in China called Jiahu.
Jiahu's a really
interesting site.
It's one of the places where the
first instances of rice being
consumed by human
beings was found.
It's one of the
first places where
there was evidence
of written language.
It's one of the
oldest places where
they found musical instruments.
It's one of the places where
civilization began, where
all of the things that we
think make us civilized people
happened first.
Well, one of the
things they found
was this pot with some
weird residue inside.
You can guess, probably
it's not a spoiler to say,
what that residue's going to be.
But they didn't know
what it was at the time.
So, the researchers who
were working the site
sent for this analytical
chemist, a guy named Patrick
McGovern, he works at the
University of Pennsylvania.
He ran a bunch of tests--
gas chromatography,
mass spectroscopy, Feigl spot
test, he shot lasers at it.
He you did all
the cool stuff you
can do if you have a lab at
Penn and found three things.
Not ethanol, I mentioned
ethanol's volatile.
Ethanol evaporates.
So even in the oldest samples,
even in the ones like the Roman
amphoras that they know
were used to carry wine,
they almost never find ethanol.
They find other stuff.
What he found was three things.
Beeswax, which you only
find if there's honey.
Rice, he found traces of rice.
And tartrates-- tartaric acid.
From anywhere else
at any other time
that would probably
have meant grapes.
But not in China,
not 10,000 years ago.
They had grapes, they
had wild species,
but they weren't common.
McGovern thinks it
was probably hawthorn,
which he says is
like a chalky apple.
It's a fruit that
has sugar in it.
Now if you mix all that stuff
together and ground it up
and let it sit, you'd have
a hard time keeping it
from fermenting.
The wild yeast, the
ambient yeast in the air,
would grab onto that.
There's a lot of sugar in there.
They would want to
make it into booze.
What McGovern had found was
the mother Eve of booze.
Honey makes mead,
rice make sake,
fruit makes wine and brandy.
It's the oldest-- the evidence
that he found on this shard,
it's the oldest example of
human controlled fermentation
that anybody's ever found.
10,000 years.
I've held this.
It's in his office, it's sitting
in a Ziploc on his shelf.
And I asked to hold it,
and he put on gloves,
he made me put on gloves,
he opened the thing.
I mean, it was a big deal.
But it was a big deal.
It's the oldest
thing I've ever held.
And it did give the sense
of a profound connection
to the first home brewer, right?
Whatever the ritual was,
whatever the ceremony was,
this is where it happened.
This thing.
10,000 years.
That's how long we've
been at it, at least.
Taming this natural
process, domesticating it,
domesticating yeast, while the
yeast domesticated us, right?
Please give me more sugar.
I will roll over with my
belly up and wag my tail
if you will just
give me more sugar.
That's the key.
Here's the only other slide.
Does anybody recognize this?
It's sugar, yeah.
It's glucose, exactly.
Simplest of simple sugars.
Six carbons in a
hexagon, some hydrogens
and oxygens dangling
off the corners.
This is the most important
molecule on earth.
Not water, water's
medium, not message.
This is message.
Sugar's power.
Just about every
form of life on Earth
uses the energy stored
in all those chemical
bonds and the lines
to stay alive.
Sugar's structure-- you get
variations in molecules,
you get different
kinds of sugars.
You can attach them together
in a bunch of different ways.
And instead of having a
monosaccharide, a single sugar,
you can have
polysaccharides, you
can have bigger
and bigger sugars.
Connect these glucose molecules
together in one specific way,
and you get cellulose.
The most common organic molecule
on earth-- wood, paper, right?
It's just repeating
elements of that.
That's the sub-unit.
Connect that same molecule
in a different way,
and you get the starches--
amylose and amylopectin.
Sugar is literally--
this is just an aside,
I'm going to do that a
lot-- sugar is literally
the backbone of our genes.
Deoxyribonucleic acid?
The ribo in there is ribose.
It's a sugar.
We're made of this.
It's our storage medium.
So that's all neat, right?
That's cool.
And like I said, yeast
eat simple sugars-- mono
and disaccharides primarily
excrete carbon dioxide,
make ethanol.
So that's all fine, if you
have a source of simple sugar.
Apples have a lot of
those simple sugars.
Honey, tons, right?
Put honey out in water and
you automatically get mead.
Grapes, grapes are
awesome, 25% simple sugar.
Every single varietal
of wine you've ever had
is one grape species.
Vitis vinifera, lucky
enough to survive an ice age
and show up in the Fertile
Crescent, Transcaucasian
Mountain area, just about
when people wanted to plant
stuff and make booze.
One researcher told me if human
beings had evolved on a Pacific
island or had started
cities on Pacific Islands
instead of in the
Transcaucasian Mountains,
then we'd have hundreds of
different species of coconut.
And grape would be a rare thing
that you found in Whole Foods
once in a while.
So that's all fine.
But what if your most easily
accessible agricultural product
stores its sugar as starch?
Because here's the problem.
You know how we in the room--
unless one of you is a mutant--
cannot digest cellulose.
We just don't know how to do it.
But we can digest starch.
There's an enzyme in
our saliva that does.
There's an amylase,
an enzyme that
digests starch, in our saliva
that begins that process.
Yeast can't do either
of those things.
So if it's grain or rice
or corn, this of barley,
it just stores all
that sugar as starch.
What do you do?
Grains are fascinating.
They're basically
little life bombs.
There's an a plant
embryo in there
and then starch to store fuel,
like a yolk in an animal egg.
That's what that starch is.
When it's time to grow, the
seeds-- the barley corns
or the grains--
make enzymes that
convert that starch into sugar.
The amylases that break it down.
And why would you
want to do that?
Fermenting and distilling
eventually are like value adds,
basically, right?
You have a whole field
full of that stuff,
it's hard to get it to market.
But if you take
that whole field,
and you turn into a
barrel of something
that you can actually
charge more for,
it's easier to
get to the market.
People want to pay
more money for it.
It's a value add.
So the way that we
do that in the West
is with a process called
malting, like single malt
scotch.
And malting basically is--
this is Glen Ord Malting,
it's owned by Diageo.
It's in the north of Scotland.
Diageo is a big
transnational drinks company.
They do almost 84 million pounds
of barley into malt a year.
It's like seven trucks a
day, every day of the year.
It only takes about 11
people to run the plant.
But basically what they're
doing in this place
is tricking barley into
thinking that it's growing.
They let it germinate.
It grows a little bit.
It starts the biochemical
processes going and making
those enzymes, converting
those starches into sugars.
And then they
arrest the process.
They stop it, so they have
access to the enzymes.
And then you can mix it
in with other grains.
And you can make beer out of it.
Distill beer and you get whisky.
Basically, anything that we make
that's fermented or distilled
in the West, starts
with malt or the enzymes
that you can extract
from the malting process.
That's fine, but what if
you were working with rice?
So if you're making sake or
rice wine, like in Japan,
they don't use malting.
They actually polish away all
of the rice bran, the thing that
makes rice brown, those are the
layers that make those enzymes.
What they do is they infect
the rice with another fungus--
yeast is a fungus.
The fungus is called koji.
Have you heard of this?
Some of the sake fans
probably know about koji.
Koji is a fungus.
It makes proteases and amylases.
It breaks down proteins,
breaks down starches.
It's the basis for
almost every Asian food.
It's how they make tofu
and vinegar and sake.
It's an Aspergillus oryzae.
And so if you know
anything about plants,
that would make you nervous
because most of the Aspergillus
species are total bastards.
They make aflatoxins,
they're carcinogenic.
The clinical literature
includes phrases
like, "bloody ball of
mucus in the lungs."
They're horrifying.
But not koji.
Koji has all the genes
that do all that stuff,
but they're all turned off.
It's domesticated, it's
another tame fungus.
We tamed it to do
one thing-- make
rice sugary so yeast can eat it.
Been around since 300 BC.
All right, so
fascinating process.
So interesting in fact, that
this guy, Jokichi Takamine,
who's a chemist born
in 1854, thought
that he could commercialize
it to not just saccharify--
the process of turning
starch into sugar
is called saccharification--
not just to saccharify rice,
but barley too.
And this was an incredible
insight on his part.
Because in the late 1880s,
researchers like the Buchner
brothers were still trying to
figure out what enzymes were.
People had just really agreed
that yeast were the things that
did fermentation
about 20 years before.
That was the discovery that
put Louis Pasteur on the map,
saying, yeah, no.
I'm pretty sure it's
the yeast, you guys.
Think about that.
10,000 years of
using the process,
of making fermented and
distilled stuff, and nobody
knew what was doing it
until the 1860s, 1870s.
And nobody knew how it
worked until much later.
It's the beginning of
biochemistry, this realization.
Fermentation.
Yeast converting
sugar to ethanol.
Takamine thought that he
could convert that process
and commercialize it.
And he actually figured out
how to grow koji on rice bran--
a throwaway product the
sake makers didn't want.
It was cheaper, it would
actually make more sugar.
And if you're a big distiller,
sugar is actually money.
You want more sugar because
you get more ethanol out of it.
He was hired by the
Whiskey Trust-- which
before prohibition was the
largest distiller in the world,
it was the American
distilling conglomerate--
to come to the US,
build the facility,
and try to commercialize
that process here,
to make whiskey without malt.
Zero malt scotch,
instead of single malt.
His English language biographer
is a woman named Joan Bennett.
And she points out
he came pretty close,
they actually sold a product for
a while called Banzai, again,
a little bit on the nose.
But things didn't work out.
One of his facilities
burned down
under mysterious
circumstances, you
can imagine the people
who made malt were not
so happy about this idea.
And the relationship
with the Whiskey Trust
fell apart, it didn't work out.
But so we still today
have this process where
we malt to make
whiskey and make beer.
I don't want you to
feel too bad for him.
He took his process
and turned it
into what Joan Bennett calls
the Alka Seltzer the 1890s,
this stuff, pocket
Taka-Diastase.
And he got so rich
that Parke Davis,
the pharmaceutical
company, bought it out.
Oh, I should say one thing
that made Takamine unique was
that unlike most
scientists of the time,
he didn't mind
patenting his processes.
So the process for
making that koji stuff
was the first English
language biotechnology patent,
depending on how you
count that kind of stuff.
Eventually Parke Davis bought
the copyright on this stuff
and set him up in a lab.
They wanted him
to figure out how
to isolate another strange and
wondrous chemical that nobody
knew how it worked.
At the time they were
calling it epinephrine.
He figured out the process
and named it adrenalin.
And he patented that too, which
led to a bunch of lawsuits,
because they made so much money.
Eventually, a judge named
Learned Hand in 1911 said,
you guys got to leave
Parke Davis alone.
It is in fact legal to patent
a naturally occurring product.
This is the decision.
This is the basis for the
modern biotechnology industry,
because of koji.
Because of the failure
of koji, really.
Takamine got so rich.
He moved to New York, he
had a beautiful mansion.
He was kind of an unofficial
technological ambassador.
And eventually it was his
money that paid for these.
These are the cherry
trees in Washington, DC.
He's the guy who bought
these, the 2,000 cherry trees.
All right, so I'm going
to jump from here back
about 2,000 years to this
place, Ancient Alexandria.
You know Alexandria,
the library.
All that Caesar, Mark
Antony, Cleopatra drama.
The lighthouse.
Founded by Alexander the Great,
it's the first modern city.
It's built on a
gridiron, designed
to take advantage of prevailing
winds off the desert.
It has a beautiful
lighthouse, it has plumbing,
it has the library
that I mentioned.
It has automatons,
they loved automatons.
They had steam engines and if
you would open a temple door,
and then the robot
god in the back
would move and
catch the sunlight,
you could put a coin into
a slot and a robot bird
would sing a song, and the
temple fire would light up.
They loved that kind of stuff.
They had parades for it.
This is a city of engineers.
They're technologists.
And more than that though,
they're alchemists.
One of the things that the
labs there are working on
is alchemy.
Now alchemy gets kind
of-- in my opinion--
it gets kind of a raw deal.
Because what we know
about alchemy is like, oh,
they were trying to
convert lead into gold.
It's the Middle Ages,
they're con artists
looking for eternal
life, Harry Potter stuff.
Fine.
Philosophically, they were
wrong about almost everything.
But methodologically
they weren't.
What they were doing was
inventing the infrastructure
for modern science.
Critically coming up with a lab
and experimentation on nature
and the stuff in that lab.
So one of the most famous
of them is this woman.
This is Maria the Jewess.
We only know mostly-- I
know, I didn't name her.
[LAUGHTER]
We know about her mostly
from a biographer who
wrote about her much later,
named Zosimos the Panopolitan.
Gotta get a "the" in my name.
Right?
How awesome would that be?
And he never really
said when she was alive,
but people think roughly the
turn of the first millennium.
Do you know what a bain-marie
is or a marienbad in a lab?
A laboratory double-boiler?
She invented that.
It's ascribed to her.
It's not the only piece
of laboratory equipment
she invented.
She also came up with this.
The one on the left is called a
kerotakis, the one on the right
is a tribikos.
Forgive my ancient Greek,
my pronunciation's terrible.
In Arabic you would call
these things put together
an al-anbiq or an alembic.
This is a still.
She came up with it.
She wanted to heat stuff
and separate it out.
There's some
disagreement about this.
The still could have been
first invented in China.
But the way I want you
to think about a still
is as a separation
technology, high technology
for separating things.
So how do we separate stuff?
Filtration, you
separate things by size.
Centrifugation, you're
separating things by weight
essentially.
You increase gravity
and the heavier stuff
falls to the bottom.
Modern practices, gas
chromatography or gel
electrophoresis, you separate
things by electrical charge.
What a still does
is separate things
based on evaporation
pressure, based on volatility.
More volatile stuff-- things
that evaporate easily--
go over the top first.
Things that evaporate with
more energy, go over later.
And you can separate things out.
You can get rid of things
you don't want and keep
the things you do,
like ethanol and water.
Different molecules evaporate
at different temperatures.
Now what--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM ROGERS: --No,
its fine, I'll stop.
Whatever, it's cool.
[LAUGHTER]
Probably what Maria was trying
to do did not involve booze.
They had access to Roman
wine in Alexandria,
but she was probably putting
in stuff like sulfur.
The alchemists were
interested in the spirits
in inanimate objects,
right, that's
where we get that word too.
So she was putting in metals
and liquids and stuff like that.
She did figure out you
need to use copper,
and you need to use solder.
And you need to keep
the heat insulated
and keep the heat
from getting out,
all the basic tenets
of distilling.
Nobody really knows if anybody
ever put that wine in the still
to see what would happen.
I like to think of her lab as
being like a graduate student
lab though.
And I figure, come
on, they must have
put-- they were
drinking all the time.
They put booze in
the still, right?
It's not clear whether they did
or not, there's other evidence.
The technology either spreads
or gets invented somewhere else.
There's evidence of it between
150 AD and 400 AD in India.
There's some reference to it in
China in 980, wine that burns.
The alcohol content would
have to be high enough
for it to burn so that it
would have to be distilled.
In about 1000 AD you
see references in Russia
to bread wine, vodka.
In the 1200s there's
a big shot alchemist
named Albertus Magnus who
writes about burning water.
But in the mid 1280s,
this guy is the one
who really puts it on the map.
He's a physician from Bologna
named Taddeo Alderotti.
He writes a book called
"Consilia Medicinalia"
where he describes the
process for making something
called aqua vita,
the water of life.
And this stuff was magic.
It would cure diseases,
it would relieve pain,
it would fix bad breath, it
would purify spoiled wine,
it would preserve meat,
you could draw essences out
of plants and smell them later.
For the first time, these
people who basically were just
witch doctors finally had a
chemical that did something.
They could make a medicine.
It felt like a medicine.
And in fact, it was just
about the only medicine
that they gave anybody who
was dying of the Black Plague.
Because they didn't
have anything else,
which contributed to the spread
of alcoholism across Europe.
What Alderotti also
figured out was
that if you added
a serpentine coil
from the top of a still and then
immersed that in cold water,
the vapors that were
coming out of that still
would condense more quickly,
and you'd get liquid.
He put the capping
technology on top of a still.
And it spread across Europe.
Everyone starts distilling.
You end up with
places like this.
This is, I think, Jim Beam.
That's the top of the
still at Jim Beam.
That's a column still.
It goes down six
floors from there.
It's 60 or 70 feet tall.
Or this.
This is St George
spirits in Alameda.
It's one of my
favorite distilleries.
And this is a new one.
This is New Caledonia
in Washington, DC.
The columns are an
interesting addition,
because what the columns do is
let you finesse that separation
process further.
The stuff you're
distilling goes in the top,
steam goes up the
bottom, and the chemicals
fractionate out in the middle.
So whatever thing you want,
you can put an outlet pipe
at a different height
on those columns
and get out the
stuff that you want.
It was a later addition
to the process.
Basically, you put the stuff you
want to distill in that big pot
and set it boiling.
And then it's plumbing,
you turn it on.
Scroll down a second, I'm
forgetting one important point.
So that precision is important,
because otherwise you
have to just time your
process of distilling,
so you don't have like
methanol in it, which is toxic.
Or you don't have kind
of yuckier flavors, which
is what comes out at the
end of a distillation.
You just want the middle,
the heart they call it.
But the important thing I want
you to take away from this
is the precision
that finally evolved.
We go from this natural
process that nobody
knows how it works
to one that we begin
to identify how it works and
can take control of, or at least
domesticate, to taking
the science of that
and turning it into a
technological process, one
that's precise, and one
that we use all the time.
That's what's happened there.
I have a couple more
things I want to say,
but I feel like I
would be cheating you
if I didn't talk a little
bit about hangovers.
[LAUGHTER]
Is that true?
I don't want to
just get out of here
without telling you
about hangovers.
Nobody knows anything
That's not totally true.
There's not a lot of science.
Here's one of the things I
love about the science of booze
is of all of the
recreational drugs
that people take-- whatever
your feelings about the legality
and morality of that are,
we take a lot of them.
Of all of those
drugs, the only one
for which scientists have not
articulated a mechanism for how
it works in the
brain is ethanol,
the one we have
taken the longest.
They don't really know.
They've got some ideas.
If you ask a researcher
who studies this stuff,
well how does marijuana work--
or methamphetamine or opium.
They know the receptor, they
know the region of the brain.
They kind of know
what's going on.
Ethanol?
We got an idea.
A couple of notions for
receptors, reaches the brain.
Partially that may be
because if you really
press a neuroscientist on
this, they don't really
know how the brain works either.
They have some good ideas.
[LAUGHTER]
A lot of the research
in alcohol and how
it affects the human
body is on dependency
and on binge drinking.
As you would imagine.
Those are problems,
and they kill people,
and they hurt people, and
they cost a lot of money.
So researchers are trying
to figure that stuff out.
But the research on-- I
try to think of my book
as taking place about three
sips into your second round.
The pivot point of
my book is the moment
when a bartender
serves you a drink.
It's about what happens when you
have one drink or two drinks.
But sometimes you mess up.
A hangover is a symptom of that.
There is not a lot of
science on hangovers.
I will tell you that almost
everything that they told you
the day before your first
weekend night of college
is wrong, or at least unproven.
So you're sitting
there and you're
thinking it's dehydration.
It's not dehydration.
Your electrolyte levels
go back to normal
when you're still
hungover and you
can rehydrate and still
have the hangover.
People think that because
alcohol suppresses
a hormone called vasopressin,
it's an anti-diuretic hormone,
it's the hormone that keeps
you from peeing all the time.
Had too much alcohol, now
you're peeing all the time.
Plus, you're not drinking water,
you're drinking beer, whatever.
So yeah, you're dehydrated.
But that's not the hangover.
People think that
it's too much sugar.
It's not.
Your sugar levels are
fine when you're hungover.
People think that it is, oh, I
had impure alcohol, congeners.
I should have had clear
liquor instead of bourbon.
It's not.
You get just as hungover with
vodka as you do with bourbon.
Some people report a worse
hangover with bourbon,
but it's mostly anecdotal.
More complicated,
acetaldehyde toxicity.
No. acetaldehyde
is hard to measure,
but your acetaldehyde
levels are zero.
Methanol toxicity.
There's some methanol
in anything fermented
and distilled.
The symptoms look
like they overlap.
It would be great,
because it's a good excuse
for the hair of the dog-- I
can explain that if you want.
But it's probably not methanol.
Nobody really knows.
What it looks like is an
inflammatory response.
Like if you have the flu,
you feel aches, you feel kind
of stupid, you
have gut problems,
your head aches-- it also has
some overlap symptomatology
with migraine.
So there are few
things that have ever
been shown in real studies to
have an effect on a hangover.
One of them is a
drug called Clotem.
It's kind of a super high
powered anti-inflammatory
that they prescribe for
migraines primarily.
You can't get it in
the United States.
I tried.
Asked a neurologist, she was
like, I'm not prescribing it.
It's not on the Pharmacopoeia,
and plus no I wouldn't.
That's stupid, I'm
not doing that.
I tried to get it
from a friend who
lived in England,
to get her to lie
to her doctor on the
National Health Service.
She was like, no, I'm
not going to do that.
So I've never tried it.
But a few things that
are sold over the counter
here have been shown
in studies to work.
Pyritinol the left is
vitamin B-6 analog.
It's two B-6 molecules
connected by a sulfur atom.
The LiverCare thing is
an Ayurvedic therapy
that's only been shown
to work in studies done
by the company that makes it, so
take that for what it's worth.
And one on the far right
is prickly pear cactus
extract, which kind of
makes sense because it has
mild anti-inflammatory
effects, prickly pear does.
It also makes a
very good burrito.
The one in the middle
is interesting,
because the one in the middle
is-- they call it BluCetin.
You can't see that well
in the picture, I'm sorry.
But it's made from a molecule
called dihydromyricetin, which
is an extract of a plant called
oriental raisin or hovenia,
which is used to
treat alcohol problems
in the traditional
Chinese pharmacopoeia.
But a lab at UCLA
looked into it,
and it does seem to affect
a receptor in the brain that
looks like it's the target for
alcohol in that relevant range
that I was talking about,
in that up to 0.06.
Like the drink and a half range.
It's a receptor
that's involved in how
we feel benzodiazepines
drugs, like Valium.
And that makes sense too,
because benzodiazepines
and alcohol always have
a synergistic effect.
They'll tell you if you're
taking a benzodiazepines don't
drink also, because it will
knock you right on your ass.
So that's a target
that some people
are looking at for what receptor
ethanol actually affects.
And this stuff is
supposed to block it.
I've tried all of those.
[EXHALES] I mean, maybe.
Don't trust anecdote
and obviously don't
do medical things that I say,
because journalist, not doctor.
That would be goofy.
But I mentioned this is
an inflammatory response.
And so now you're thinking,
because you're smart,
you're like, I'm just going
to take ibuprofen, right?
Anti-inflammatory.
Here's the thing.
Ibuprofen has as a side effect
gastrointestinal problems.
Take a lot of it,
you get a GI bleed.
You already have
gastrointestinal problems
from the hangover, so
now you're thinking,
oh, well I'll take
it with a Pepcid.
And now you're taking
a fistful of stuff
that you're not really sure
is going to work, which
makes me nervous,
I have to admit.
But also-- so in the excerpt of
the book that ran in "Wired,"
I said I've started taking
a couple of ibuprofen
before I go to bed
or when I wake up.
And people came
at me on Twitter.
You're going to get a GI bleed.
Like how often do you
think I'm doing this?
[LAUGHTER]
No, no, no.
Settle down.
This is not-- I don't
think it's a problem yet.
Of course, like nobody
ever does, right?
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, so I wish I had
better news about hangovers.
The anti-inflammatory thing
I think has possibilities.
So where does that leave us.
So I was in Japan a couple of
weeks ago, family vacation.
And the Imperial Hotel
in Tokyo right now
is this giant, brutalist,
skyscraper-looking place,
very ugly.
But the original
Imperial Hotel in Tokyo
was built by Frank Lloyd Wright.
It was one of the most
beautiful buildings anywhere.
Like so many Frank
Lloyd Wright buildings,
it fell down in the 1960s.
Not a good engineer,
Frank Lloyd Wright.
But the one place
in the building
that still has the original
Frank Lloyd Wright appointments
is the old bar.
So you can go to the old
Imperial Bar in the hotel,
and it has beautiful
Frank Lloyd Wright wall
hangings and the
tiles and stuff.
It's really nice and it's
a very nice cocktail bar,
so I wanted to go.
Because I-- I ordered this
drink call the Gemini,
it's their house
drink, it was terrible.
But the coaster's
really nice, right?
It's a beautiful coaster.
Because I wanted to feel
the connection to history,
to a Frank Lloyd Wright
building and to the history
of cocktails.
And that's a thing that
alcohol will give you,
is that connection down
through shallow time,
with Frank Lloyd Wright and
then deeper with the people who
first started making
gin, for example,
which human beings
were making 1,000 years
before they knew how it worked.
They were making it without
really knowing how to make it.
They still don't really know
why we taste it the way we do.
We make this stuff, and
it affects our senses--
our sense of smell and taste.
And you and I would
taste the same thing
and if we told each other
that it tasted the same to us,
we might be talking about
actually different flavors
in our heads, or we might
taste entirely different things
in it, and nobody
really knows why.
It alters our bodies,
it changes our minds,
and nobody really knows how.
They're working on it.
We taste it differently, we
feel its effects differently,
every culture that uses it
has different rituals for it
and manifest the effects
of that differently.
We have cracked open yeast
and the other microbes that
are responsible for it and begun
to understand that biology.
Yeast are an incredibly
important model organism
in science.
They were the
first organism that
was ever a genetic sequence for.
So we've gone from the
agricultural process
of domesticating a microbe
we only understood vaguely
to the cold precision
of genetic engineering.
But really, we were making
booze before we had science,
much less before we
had booze science.
Now that we have
all that science,
now that we understand
it a little bit more,
I don't want you to think that
that makes the stuff that we
drink less magical,
less amazing.
I'm, I guess, paraphrasing
Arthur C Clarke a little bit.
Magic is just
advanced technology.
The science that we
use to make this stuff
is what makes the magic.
What I want to argue, and
what I want to leave you with,
is this notion that when
you are tasting something
that you're drinking-- whatever
it is, if you're tasting
the strawberry notes in a
nice glass of white wine
or the smoke in a
peated Ila whisky--
that while you are tasting
all those things what you're
actually tasting, those flavors
and aromas you are tasting
is civilization.
Thank you.
That's what I've got.
[APPLAUSE]
Look, it's my desktop.
Sorry about that.
I can do questions for a bit.
Do we have time for that?
Is that OK?
I can't tell if you're walking
out or asking questions.
You have to tell me.
Oh good.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds like a
lot of the process of making
booze is to get to the sugar.
So, can I just put
water and sugar, and--
ADAM ROGERS: Yeah, please.
Listen, some of my
hyperbole is intentional.
So go ahead and challenge away.
Oh, Yeah.
No totally, well I mean
that's what rum is.
AUDIENCE: Can I just buy
Domino sugar and make--
ADAM ROGERS: Yeah, that's rum.
A lot of the rum that we
drink-- I mean, not exactly.
Well, let me calibrate
that slightly.
Most rum is made from molasses.
Molasses is a byproduct
of processing sugar cane
into sugar.
If you want to make
white powdered sugar,
you end up with a
lot of molasses,
which ferments really easily.
In fact, it ferments so
easily that you really
want your rum distillery next
to your sugar cane processing
plant, because it comes
right out of there.
And you've got to get
it into the still,
because otherwise all the
wild stuff's going to colonize
and it will go bad.
You can also make a drink
called Rhum Agricole.
Rhum Agricole is
made from cane juice.
So you can just squeeze sugar
cane, have you ever tasted it?
It's delicious just like that.
It's not super sweet,
it's just really good.
And you can distill that,
make a Rhum Agricole.
It's a product that
got made in a lot
of the former French
colonies in South America
and in the Caribbean.
You can find them.
They're delicious.
They're really interesting, they
smell kind of funky and grassy.
And if you're making
moonshine-- famously moonshine
is whiskey, un-aged whiskey.
But like cheap moonshine--
especially present day,
cheap, illegal
moonshine-- is often
like they go buy a lot of sugar,
ferment that, and distill it.
Or they use any sugar substrate.
I've seen a mash
made from donuts.
Tastes as good as
you would expect.
[LAUGHTER]
What else?
AUDIENCE: So a
lot of the liquors
have precursors, like
whiskey is distilled beer.
ADAM ROGERS: Right.
AUDIENCE: And brandy
is distilled--
ADAM ROGERS: Wine.
AUDIENCE: --Wine.
Who thought up vodka?
ADAM ROGERS: Well, so, a lot
of people who think about booze
or who write about
it go by category.
It's a perfectly good heuristic.
Wine, beer, tequila,
rum, scotch, whatever.
They write about
a specific thing.
I'm intentionally forcing
a different heuristic,
which is process.
Which goes-- and this is
the structure of the book.
Starts with yeast,
goes to sugar,
you ferment that, you distill
it, you can age it in a barrel.
Then you taste and smell it.
Take a drink, has affect on
your body, on your brain.
And any alcohol, any booze
falls under those categories.
So vodka is easy,
because vodka, you
can use any substrate you want.
And famously it's oh,
Russians had potatoes.
But you can make
it out of anything,
because all you're doing is
running it through the still so
many times that
you're stripping out
every molecule, except
ethanol and water.
In fact, in the United States
if you're selling vodka,
that's all that's
allowed to be in it.
Those are the only molecules.
It's just H2O and ethanol.
That's it.
Which is weird, because
they taste different.
So you go well,
how does that work?
Maybe the levels of alcohol
are different, sometimes.
But if they all say 80 proof,
they're all 40% percent ABV.
If it's all 40% ethanol
molecules and 60% water
molecules, what's going on?
Some of it might
just be marketing.
Theater is super
important with booze.
Marketing in the
theater of-- you
know, imagine that bottle of red
wine that you had on that trip
where you got lost and you found
that perfect little trattoria
in Tuscany.
And you got that
bottle and it was
like the best
bottle of red wine.
And then you get
the stuff at home
and watching it in front
of a "Star Trek" rerun
it doesn't quite--
it's not really as good
out of the Mason jar.
It's like well, it's still good.
Don't get me wrong.
Plus this is the one with
the green Orion slave girl.
[LAUGHTER]
Always makes wine better.
But there's a hypothesis.
I have a paper that's
pretty great that
suggests that the relationship
between those molecules
can change depending on
levels, because the water forms
what are called clathrates.
Basically they're
kind of H2O crystals
that surround the ethanol.
And the different
shapes of those crystals
might be perceptible as a
matter of flavor or aroma.
It's tantalizing as a paper.
And it was a pretty
good paper that I
don't know that
anybody followed up on.
It also, of course, came out of
a lab in Russia, as you expect.
What else?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the hair of the dog.
Can you talk a little
more about that?
ADAM ROGERS: Yeah, good,
thank you for reminding me.
So there used to
be a whole class
of cocktails called pick me ups.
And the pick me ups
were drinks that
were designed to
drink in the morning,
because everybody was
drunk all the time.
[LAUGHTER]
Awesome.
It's what it's like
at Yahoo, not Google.
You guys don't drink like that.
You don't see many
of them anymore.
So the last one--
acceptable morning
drinks now, the bloody
family, like a Bloody Maria
or a Caesar or a Bloody Mary,
and a Mimosa, you see those.
The Corpse Reviver Number Two?
Do you know this drink?
I love that drink.
It's a great drink.
The Corpse Reviver Number Two
does not refer to zombies.
The corpse in that name
is the hungover person
who has dragged
himself into a bar,
before going to work that
day to try to come back.
So that's hair of the dog.
The idea is that
if you're hungover
you have a little bit
of booze, and that
makes you not feel
the hangover anymore.
So probably all it does is
just delay the hangover,
because you're more
relaxed about it.
But there is a theory.
I mentioned methanol toxicity.
There is a theory that says
that a hangover are actually
the symptoms of a very, very,
small amount of methanol.
So methanol's really cool.
It's a different alcohol.
And alcohol
dehydrogenase-- we all
make that too,
that's how we process
alcohol in our own bodies--
will work on methanol also.
But instead of
having ethanol, which
it can change into
acetaldehyde aldehyde
in us, when it
works on methanol,
it changes it into
formaldehyde, which is bad.
Doesn't last long in the
body, it's not good for you,
but it kind of goes away.
But it turns into
formic acid, which
is the stuff in ant venom.
So you get acidosis.
Formic acid interferes
with the enzyme
that we use to process
oxygen in our cells.
So the heaviest oxygen
users in our body
are the eyes and the brain.
That's why when you
have oxygen deprivation
the first thing that happens
is you stop seeing colors.
And then you get
that tunnel that
closes in when
you're not breathing.
Formic acid messes with
the enzyme that does that.
It's why methanol toxicity
will make you go blind.
And eventually it goes into the
brain, messes with the brain's
ability to deal with oxygen,
you get Parkinsonian tremor.
Eventually, it kills you.
But if you show up in an
emergency room with methanol
toxicity, not that
I'm recommending this,
the first thing
the doctors will do
is they will give you a
giant dose of ethanol.
Because ethanol displaces
the methanol off the enzyme.
The enzyme would much
rather work on ethanol.
They hit you with the
ethanol, the enzyme
throws the methanol overboard,
goes to work on the ethanol,
and you excrete the methanol
through your breath,
and you pee it out.
Basically, that's
the therapy for it.
So the notion is if a
hangover is methanol toxicity,
you're going to
have another drink,
the ethanol will displace
the methanol off the enzyme,
and you will feel better.
That's the theory--
that's the hypothesis,
nobody's proved that.
It's a great just-so story.
It sounds terrible.
It sounds like an awful solution
to me that I have not tried.
The other bad
thing about this is
that according to
some studies, the kind
of person who-- it's like
10% of the people who
admit to trying hair of
the dog regularly also
end up becoming alcoholics.
They sound related,
but not causal, right?
AUDIENCE: So I know
that a lot of alcohol
relies on wild yeast,
but when people--
ADAM ROGERS: Relies on sorry?
AUDIENCE: --On wild yeast.
ADAM ROGERS: Oh,
wild yeast, sure.
AUDIENCE: So when
did people start
isolating yeast and
actually culturing it?
ADAM ROGERS: Yeah, I
don't know if there's
a great answer to that.
There is a notion--
you can imagine
at first it's all
just your starter.
Just like people had
sourdough starters
that they would pass down.
So you'd go, well that winery
over there makes good wine
regularly, and that winery
on that hill doesn't.
So I'm going to buy
it from over there,
without knowing it's
because their yeast sucks
and their yeast
works really well.
But you get until
the late 1880s when
people start to really
kind of consciously
study the yeast strain and
make sure it's working.
And a lot of that comes out
of-- oh, which brewery is it.
I'm not going to remember.
But a specific lager
maker in Germany,
where they were like
we're going to have a lab.
We're going to
understand our yeast.
We're going to figure
out where it comes from.
For a while they even thought
they had a unique yeast.
It's Carlsberg.
So they started calling it
Saccharomyces carlsbergensis.
That was making
their exact lager.
Turns out it probably was a
mix of a couple other strains
that nobody knows where one of
them came from yet actually.
But it was late
where people started
to really focus on that.
And there's still a
controversy in distilling,
especially about how important
the strain of yeast is.
Whether you can just use
any old commodity yeast,
or whether you need
your specific one.
Brewers, especially-- you know
any home brewers you know this.
They'll be very specific
about like that's a yeast
that you make a very specific
kind of beer with, ale,
whatever.
And they want to stick with it.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the alchemists
and the early alcohol things.
And they mixed them with
herbals and made medicines.
And being Italian, I'm a fan
of amaros and herbal things
and get my Fernet
Branca after dinner.
Do you think there's
a direct link--
ADAM ROGERS: Must be
from San Francisco.
AUDIENCE: --No, New
York, born and bred.
Do you think there was
a direct link from that.
I mean, did they take the
medicines and carry it forward,
and people said,
you know what, I'm
going to drink this any time.
Or was it lost and rediscovered?
ADAM ROGERS: You can
still get the drinks that
are if not the actual
recipe, descendants
of the recipe, from
the monks taking
the herbs in their garden and
macerating it in neutral spirit
or distilling it with.
You know, Chartreuse--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess.
ADAM ROGERS: --And Benedictine.
Benedictine, right?
Benedictine monks
make Benedictine.
That's why it's called that.
That's why I like the amari
and Chartreuse and Benedictine
especially, because I feel like
that's a connection to at least
to the 1600s and what
they were making then.
It's the same recipe.
Probably tastes different
for a lot of other reasons.
But if what you're asking is
when did it stop being medicine
and become fun--
AUDIENCE: Sort of.
ADAM ROGERS: --That
is less clear.
Although, there's a chunk
of history in the book,
but there's not a lot of
cocktail history, I'll admit.
But I've read a lot
of it and I like it.
So some of that
mixing traces back,
interestingly, I think, not
to bars but to pharmacies.
So pharmacies were also
allowed to dispense alcohol
in this country
in the early '18s.
So call it '10s, '20s.
Pharmacists were allowed
to dispense alcohol.
They were also allowed
to dispense things
like extract of cocaine and
opiates and stuff like that.
And they were also places where
unlike bars, women could go,
so they were more
social in their own way.
There's a book called
"Fix the Pumps"
by a guy named Darcy O'Neill
that's great about this.
And one of the things
that Darcy says,
is these pharmacists were
making bitters, tonics,
that you could mix
with soda water.
That's where Coca
Cola comes from,
it's where Dr. Pepper--
like Dr. Pepper.
That's his recipe.
Or Boker's Bitters
or Angostura Bitters.
That's where all that
stuff comes from.
These ingredients-- so
you begin to be like,
oh, I'll mix that up, and
maybe I'll put some ice in it.
And there's ice cream.
You could have ice cream
at the soda fountain too.
So that's where at least
what we would consider
the modern version of
the cocktail comes from.
And it transitions from being
a medication-- or at least
something that we
all just say is
a medication-- into something
that's recreational.
AUDIENCE: I like I like
some really old whiskey's.
ADAM ROGERS: Me too.
Man.
AUDIENCE: Unfortunately
they're very expensive.
ADAM ROGERS: I know.
It sucks.
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering if
you see a future in which we
may have a better scientific
understanding of what the aging
process does, and we may be able
to imitate it in a shorter time
period and get them
less expensive?
ADAM ROGERS: Holy
smoke, are there
some people who would like
to know the answer to that.
And for real, not just
as an abstract concept.
But if you are a small
distiller, a craft distiller
who's trying to
make a brown spirit,
you don't have time to wait.
You don't have enough
stock to wait for 10 years
before you can start
selling things.
You need to start
selling stuff now.
And if you'd like
to make whiskey,
you want to accelerate
the process.
So without understanding
the chemistry well yet,
because they don't,
one of the approaches
is to use a smaller barrel.
You probably know this, right.
Use a smaller barrel
and you get more surface
of the wood exposed to more,
relatively, of the liquid.
The problem with that is you
get all the extractives out
of the wood, but you don't
get any of the oxidation
or esterification that
comes with just time.
So people will try other tricks
to try to make that happen.
There's a distillery that
actually plays heavy bass music
at their barrels to try
to get the vibration,
so they get more exposure
and mix it up more.
There's a company
called Terressentia
that says that they
have a process that
combines sonification--
or sonication?
Sonification I guess is if
you're playing the video game.
Anyway.
It combines a processing
sound with some kind
of filtration
technology that they
can make something taste older.
I've had it.
It tastes I guess fine.
It didn't necessarily
taste older to me.
AUDIENCE: So you're not
necessarily convinced yet?
ADAM ROGERS: No.
I'm not convinced of that.
And I think also
what is happening
is that a lot of
distillers are starting
to try to say that the flavors
that you get from something
that is not aged for a long time
are not a bug, but a feature.
They're saying, oh no, we're
making something different
here.
But I know that there
are small distillers who
can age for not eight years,
but some shorter amount of time
and still pretty something
that's really spectacular.
So there are some
methodological things going on.
Whether anybody will ever
be able to say, oh OK, well
here's my oldness extract--
you know, doop doop doop--
and then there you go.
I don't know, although that's
standard practice in some
of the most traditional
drinks you can think of.
If you're making cognac,
super appellation controlled,
a lot of rules,
old brand-- Cognac
is brandy from a
particular region, made
in a particular way-- you're
allowed to add something
called the-- my French is
as bad as my ancient Greek,
I'm sorry-- a boise.
And what it is
essentially is tannic tea.
And they'll keep the same
kind of water soaking
in really tannic
wood for 50 years.
And they can add that
to their product.
And it makes it
darker and you get
a more of a big,
mellow, older flavor.
And some winemakers
will do that too.
They'll age in a big
steel vat, but they'll
soak tea bags full of
sawdust, essentially,
in there to get some of
the wood flavors into it.
So Yeah, they're trying.
But the specific
processes do seem
to require time in the equation.
AUDIENCE: So I guess as
a piggyback question off
of that and a lot of the
things you mentioned,
we're about the process.
And you have this overarching
idea of the process.
Is there a piece of that
process that's sort of yet
to be invented?
I mean I think a
lot of the things
that you just mentioned are
ways we can use modern science
and understanding to replace
or advance are quicken
or make that process
more efficient.
But is there some great
leap of technology
waiting for booze
that will take it
to the next sort of
amazing euphoric level?
ADAM ROGERS: Let
me give you two.
One is genetically engineering
yeast to do other stuff.
So there's a
researcher in Australia
named Isaac Pretorius,
and he worked on a yeast
that-- I'm going to radically
simplify this, I'm sorry,
this is terrible.
Basically, it would take crummy
grapes and make decent wine.
Because it was able to break
a particular molecular bond
that was liberating
a flavor that you
wanted in Sauvignon blanc
that they were growing
in too hot a climate for
Sauvignon blanc, essentially.
There's a woman in France
named Sylvie Dequin,
and she's working
on yeasts that will
make wine that tastes good,
but has lower alcohol levels.
You might know this, but
especially in California wines,
alcohol, ABV's creeping up.
Because the yeast that they're
using and the process they're
using is more efficient.
They're getting more
alcohol off the sugar.
So you end up with
wine that used
to be 8%, 9%, you can get it
at 15, which is super high.
And it does-- I mean it's
a flavor that people like,
but also you're blitzed
on a glass of wine.
So she's working on
yeast that won't do that.
You still get the flavor,
but not the alcohol.
Of course nobody in the
world-- I shouldn't say that.
If you have a GMO yeast,
you can't sell it in Europe.
And you'd have trouble selling
it here, you'd get controversy.
So after Pretorius
made that yeast,
once he knew which genes it
was, he went back and did
it standard breeding, he grew
a strain up without genetically
modifying it and he sells that.
So there's room in the
yeast, to mess with yeast
and come up with something new.
The other thing
that's probably true,
there's a researcher
in England, works
on drugs and alcohol,
named David Nutt.
And he was actually in
charge of UK drug policy
until he had the
temerity to suggest
that they were
over-regulating marijuana
and under-regulating
alcohol, so they fired him.
He says that he has a few
different compounds based
on benzodiazepines
that if you take them,
they make you feel exactly
the same way as having
a drink or two, but
they're reversible.
But they have an antidote.
He says.
So since it's synthehol.
He's published on
the idea, and he's
published sort of the
vague how it might work.
And he says he's tried his
own and taken the antidote,
and it worked.
But as far as I've
found-- if you guys have
one of these papers, tell me--
he hasn't sent me a paper.
I asked him.
He wouldn't talk to me, but
he sent me a couple of papers.
He hasn't published the
here's the compound,
here's the test, here's
how I know it works.
He says he needs the funding
to do it, which is always
a dicey thing for research.
It's like if you guys
give me more money, then
I'll give you the thing.
But intriguing, right?
Maybe less fun, comes
in a pill, instead of
as a Corpse Reviver Number Two.
But an intriguing advance
in how we get buzzed.
Anything else?
That's a pretty good
beat to stop on anyway.
Oh, one more.
Sure, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: To pick
one favorite drink.
ADAM ROGERS: Cocktail or--
no, see, here's the thing.
I'm the most annoying person
in the world to drink with now.
I'm so unpleasant
now, not because-- I'm
working really hard on not being
judgey about people's drinks.
I'm getting there, I'm evolving.
Is that really a
chocolate martini, really?
OK, if you like the
chocolate martini,
you can have the
chocolate martini.
But I get that question
and I get all contextual.
I'm like, well, am
I-- is it hot out?
Is it the end of the day?
Is it evening, or am
I about to go out,
or is this after dinner?
The truth is that the thing
that kind of got me into this--
though there are a lot of
things that got me into this--
was single malt whisky.
And that's still I think,
along with with the Shinkansen
and rocket ships, I
think single malt whisky
may be one of the pinnacles
of human achievement.
So it's probably that.
Thank you very much you guys.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]